منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وحتى هذه اللحظه
تتفاقم هنا الازمات في شمال قطاع غزه ومع
منع دخول المساعدات والعلاجات ايضا
والادويه الاساسيه لاصحاب الامراض المزمنه
وتوقف عمل الوكاله بالكامل هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه ادى الى ازدياد عدد الوفيات
نتيجه عدم توفر هذه العلاجات الاساسيه هنا
في شمال القطاع بدي اخذ للحاج مش ملاقي
اخذ لي دواء ضغط انا نزات نفسي معي ضغط مش
ملاقي دواء الضغط بيجي عندهم مره بناخذ
ومره بناخذ اليوم اجينا بقول لا في دواء
ضغط ولا دواء سكري ولا في دوا اي ممنوع اي
دوا مزمن يعني اليوم الناس المزمنه تقريبا
تنعد من عداد الشهداء بقولوا فيش دواء
بروح ندور على الصيدليه نشتري دواء بلاقي
الصيدليات مسكره فيش صيدليات في عنا ادويه
هيي شهرين ببني اولاد ابني ثلاثه ع مش
لاقين علاج لهم الصغار حتى انا اللي ماليش
انا بقوح راشح ماليش بنتي ماتت من الاسهال
من قله العلاج اللي عندهم فيش علاج
[موسيقى]
بالمره احنا هنا قاعدين في مستودع للادويه
في عياده الوكاله وهي طبعا المستودع خالي
من كل الادويه لا يوجد ادويه للمرضى واحنا
بعد ما ان قصفت بيتنا واستشهد زوجي لجات
كواء في هذه الغرفه وهينا قاعدين ولا يعني
مش متوفر لنا اي خدمات من جهه اليوان
والمخزن وهي زي ما انتم شايفين المخزن
فاضي لا يتوفر فيه اي علاجات او اي ادويه
لاي مريض احنا هن من اول حرب نازحين من
النازحين العادي زوجي مريض ى وقلب وسكري
اي ومعاه ضغط
وبتصالح
اي كل هذه الامراض هي يعني في وال وقعدنا
يعني حوالي ثلاث شهور لا في علاج
ولا مش موفر اي حاجه لا من الوكاله ولا من
الدول المانحه او اي اي مساعدات ما في حتى
كانه هو مريض كى ما بيغسلو ما فيش
مستشفيات لغسيل الكلى وجوز توفى بهذا
المكان هون كانت فرش بالضبط وتوفى هذا
المكان لا قادره اخذه ولا قادره اجيبه
ونشرت وعملت مناشدات ولا حد يقدر يعمل لي
اي حاجه ولا شي وتوفى
هنا معاناه المرضى تزداد يوما بعد يوم في
ظل غياب كامل للوكاله هنا في شمال قطاع
غزه وايضا عدم توفر العلاجات الاساسيه
لاصحاب الامراض المزمنه انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال
غزه